Windsor Castle the longest occupied
palace in Europe has been the residents
of 40 of England's monarchs since its
founding by William the Conqueror in the
11th century the Queen grew up in
Windsor so it was her childhood home and
she continues to come here most weekends
it's a place where she feels comfortable
if she knew we were here do you think
she'd have us over for tea I think she
probably all Charlotte Manley is a
chapter clerk at st. George's Chapel was
started in 1475 and it's at about fifty
years to build it and it's a wonderful
example of a particular kind of
architecture called perpendicular with
tall soaring columns lots of lights
coming in and lots of glass when you
heard that they wanted to be married
here because this is your home - yes
what did you think I thought it was
wonderful the more than 500 year old
chapel within the walls at Windsor is
where Prince Charles celebrated his
marriage to Camilla parker-bowles
back in 2005 though a number of
commoners have also married here
meg and Marco will be the first American
but the role of her royal is one the
actress rehearsed early on with her
childhood friends her friends were
certainly on to something because Megan
Markel will indeed become her Royal
Highness when she walks down the aisle
here at st. George's Chapel so it's no
surprise to you that Harry and Megan
wanted to be married here then it's a
really nice for us that they've chosen
some George's there other places they
could have chosen but they've chosen
this place which has a personal intimate
feel than other places while Prince
William and Kate Middleton said their
vows in front of an audience of roughly
2,000 at Westminster Abbey
it's an osteopath fewer than half will
witness the wedding inside the chapel
when I first heard Charlotte that it was
going to be an intimate wedding of 600 I
said how is a wedding of 600 intimate
well if you compare it back to the
Victorian days when while weddings were
held here they were small-scale because
it was just what if family attended
crowds will also fill the castle grounds
the streets of Windsor and many millions
more are expected to tune in throughout
the world
Charlotte manly is not feeling the
pressure what's keeping you up at night
as we do the wedding countdown I sleep
very little because you're ready after
spending time with Charlotte manly I
know that Prince Harry and Meg and Marco
are in very good hands she's got
everything under control as you could
tell she is no joke